we're less than a month away from the
next anime season so now's a good time
to talk about what we've got lined up i
already have an idea what you guys are
eagerly anticipating this upcoming
season but i hope that through this list
which has no sequels i can introduce you
to even more cool shows that you might
be interested in as usual i would ask
for your help in increasing the
channel's reach and subscriber count you
can do that by clicking the subscribe
button ringing the bell and sharing the
news of this channel with all of your
friends now let's get started
[Music]
starting off the list is sakugan far
into the future humanity's found itself
doing what it does best in anime being
pushed aside and struggling to live in
the harshest conditions now residing in
colonies within the underground world
labyrinth humanity has adapted to the
new life not so for our protagonists
though the daughter father duo of
momentful and ganbar one day they begin
their perilous journey at the behest of
momentum with the end goal of finding
her mother along the way more awards
awaited as gaganbar's map of the
dangerous world outside could fetch an
absurdly high price but is this price
worth the peril what secrets and truths
await at the duo at the end of it all
i've got to admit i never read the
source material for this one however
what i can see from the previews is a
fun exciting adventure series full of
thrills some have compared it to fallout
and i think i'd have to agree however
what i'm looking forward to the most in
this series is the potential of seeing a
budding development in the bond between
father and daughter
number nine is the world's best assassin
to reincarnate in a different world
aristocrat being a hired gun is tough
the world of assassins is a dangerous
place and i'm not just talking about the
targets you set out to assassinate you
can't afford to even blink for your
greatest enemies can come from the
closest places and that's something that
our protagonist here has to find out the
hard way however he gets a second chance
at life as luge and along with it comes
a gargantuan task he's got to eliminate
a super powerful hero who has the
potential to bring the end of the world
he may have been a proficient hero in
his life on earth but how is he gonna
fare when an unwanted harem and magic
get thrown into the equation i really
look forward to how the story is gonna
proceed from this point i've always
enjoyed assassin type protagonists and
this show looks like it's something that
most people would enjoy it certainly
isn't the most common reincarnation
story i think it's something that will
satisfy that itch for a more unique
premise in isakai it's something that
people will probably enjoy
[Applause]
eighth on the list is the vampire dies
in no time when talking about vampires
what comes to your mind probably those
unbelievable beautiful aristocrats or
those nine invincible boss monsters that
only come with a few weaknesses well
draluk is none of that first of all he's
quite the bro loving video games and
he's so hilariously weak that he dies to
anything that's certainly not what
ronaldo expected when he goes to
draluk's castle hoping to rescue a
supposedly kidnapped child with his
castle's destruction draenock moves into
ronaldo's office and hilarity ensues
however it's not all fun and games
though as danger lurks in the shadows
how will the odd couple survive the
onslaught of rogue vampires and
investigators out to get them now this
is a series that i can definitely get
behind i've seen quite a number of
vampire anime but never have i seen
anything this casual and light-hearted
bloodland probably but most of the
vampire shows i've watched or held their
kind to some sort of reverence this
however feels like a complete comedy
that i feel will come with some serious
dramatic moments and unexpectedly good
action
next up we have thai show maiden fairy
tale
[Music]
could have had the world being born into
a wealthy family he could have had the
world at his fingertips that never made
him happy not with such a neglectful
family that never gave him the love he
desired not helping matters is his
handicap which made his father cast him
out into isolation before the wheels can
fully fall off salvation comes in the
form of yuzuki a girl claiming to have
been sent to be his wife with their help
tamahiko starts his road to recovery
finding new meaning in what is a
desolate life now with love in the air
how will the two stories intertwine in
mahiko of his emotional scars some major
don't ignore feels anyone i feel this is
one of the comfy anime of the season and
while i'm not sure if healing anime is
the right term for it it probably comes
with a lot of scenes that will target
your heartstrings i've yet to read the
source material but i can already see
the feels and cute romantic moments
coming from the premise alone probably a
show i'll recommend for those who want
to unwind
[Music]
talk about something fitting for the
halloween season marukojan is the story
of mikko someone who seems to be your
typical high school student one problem
is though she suddenly starts seeing
gruesome monsters all over the place
however she's no ichigo and she proceeds
to carry on her everyday life trying her
best to ignore all these horrors that
surround her of course that's a task
easier said than done isn't it
especially if you start seeing your
friend hana get in the line of danger it
really begs the question how much longer
can she attempt to ignore the events
that are happening around her
meruko-chan from what i've read in the
manga is a mostly episodic series
focusing on mikko's misadventures as she
tries to cope with the supernatural
what's unique about the series is that
this isn't your typical girl learns to
fight monsters fair and leans more on
the black comedy aspects of it i also
like how the story eventually gets very
interesting with its slew of characters
and plot progression if you're out for
some casual spooks you should definitely
put this one on your watch list before
we move on let me ask you a question
have you ever felt like the internet
isn't a safe place heck let's not even
go down that route let's flat out say
that the internet is a dangerous place
even your incognito modes won't save you
and that's a fact fortunately you've got
this video sponsor expressvpn to save
the day it allows you smooth sailing on
the web without the fear of any bad guys
there to steal your data hey it also
provides some cool perks too as someone
living in asia right now i find a lot of
anime that i want to watch to be
unavailable on the usual legal sites
especially some of the shows that i'm
going to be talking about however all i
needed to do was to turn on expressvpn
just pick your server of choice wait a
few seconds and then start watching your
favorite anime i used this when i was
traveling all over the world and i never
missed a beat when i was trying to watch
the second season of attack on titan as
a simulcast back then and hey did you
know my hero academia is being
simulcasted in south asia right now if
you want to watch the fifth season right
now on netflix you can watch it by
changing the server to india so even if
you live in the us you can use
expressvpn to get access to thousands of
new shows and anime on streaming
services like netflix simply by changing
your location to another country so to
give you a gift i proudly present three
months free of expressvpn all you have
to do is click the link in the
description box or go to
www.expressvpn.com
vinnie tube it's an amazing deal that
would be a shame to miss out on so hurry
up and get access to the best surfing
buddy you could ever hope to have fifth
on the list is tact up destiny video
game times can be hit or miss however i
want to stay on the optimistic course
and say that while we've had mediocre
titans like gunslinger stratos or god
eater recent video game titans like the
two latest bang dream seasons or
princess connect have been pretty good
actually tact up destiny looks to
continue the trend as it takes us to a
dystopian society ruled by creatures
called the d2 seemingly invincible these
alien invaders have one glaring weakness
music thankfully a light of hope shines
in the world in the form of the
conductor and his allies the music
wielding music art is it me or can i
feel some of vivi's imprints somewhere
in this series well catching up to the
former's excellence is a long and
difficult task tactop destiny seems to
be a show that's in good hands with mapa
and madhouse teaming up for this one
this seems to be one of the fun non-stop
action series that has its fair share of
fights and attractive girls that will
undoubtedly charm any viewer let's see
if the tactile franchise gets the opener
that it deserves with this anime
this one got me at the first half the
faraway paladin is the story of william
maryblood a lone human born in the city
of the dead raised by the undead he's
left with only vague memories of the
past looking for a purpose and soon
taking the mantle of an aspiring paladin
he soon departs with the pressing
question about his true identity the
faraway paladin is this season's most
anticipated itsakai and for good reason
too people have lauded its excellence in
characterization but i think that what
interests me more is the world i
personally have grown quite weary of
high fantasy settings that are so
prominent in the genre but with what
i've seen so far the world and the
mysteries of far away paladin have
captivated me i want to know more and
the author seems to have weaved together
a very interesting universe in which to
set the epic journey in it's the most
anticipated new isakai this fall and i
squarely fall within the group of people
eagerly wanting to experience william
mary blood's journey of self-discovery
kicking off our top three now we have
the psychological thriller platinum
[Music]
are back once again with a title that
seems to return the duo to their roots
to the title that put them on the map
death note platinum end tells the story
of mirai a gloomy boy who fed up with
his life attempts suicide it wouldn't
come to pass as he gets saved by a
guardian angel introducing herself as
nasa instead of letting him die nasa
grants him supernatural powers and a new
calling in life finding and defeating 12
other candidates in a battle royale to
determine the next god of the world he's
given
999 days to do it and he has to put out
everything in that arsenal of is to
survive this battle royale for the ages
this looks to be a more action-centric
series something that we've yet to see
this duo in i'm excited to see how it's
going to go having read the first parts
of the manga i wonder if the duo will
strike gold again right after barkleman
and death note and that's got me very
excited to see how this adaptation is
going to turn out
second place on the list is blue period
[Music]
life can be boring and repetitive right
especially these days there seems to be
the creeping feeling that we just go
through the motion drone on and just
drag ourselves through this long
marathon called life don't you wish to
do something just a bit more exciting
and meaningful those are the sentiments
held by yatora luckily for him he soon
learns about the joy of drawing picking
up his brush he starts conveying his
feelings not through words but by
drawing however the world of art isn't
an easy one with challenges and multiple
obstacles standing in his way his love
for the craft and his determination will
be tested flu period seems to be one of
the more serious new anime we've coming
this new season and i'm really looking
forward to it being a frustrated artist
myself it's something that i can
actually relate to i'm sure that a lot
of you do as well whether you're the
type who's into art or not you'll
definitely find something to pick up
from this title the most anticipated new
anime for this season is none other than
gomi-san can't communicate
oh boy i remember when this anime first
got announced my social media news feed
simply just blew up in anticipation at
long last the highly acclaimed manga
will be getting its anime adaptation
it's been a long time coming and it's a
very well deserved adaptation of that
the show's premise is very very simple
we have the titular kami-san idol of the
entire edan private high school long
admired for her beauty however there's
one problem she's absolutely terrible at
communicating with others also another
problem indirectly related to her is
that she turns her seat mate into the
enemy of the jealous class as tadano
would find out an event leads tardano to
find out gomi's secret and seeing if she
has no other friends he resolves to help
her make a hundred friends in order to
help her overcome her issues the hype is
real for kami-san and i can't wait to
finally see one of my favorite rom-coms
in anime form if you're just excited as
i am to see kami-san finally animated
don't forget to tell me in the comments
section below well with the list being
done it's time to start voting what you
think will be your favorite new fall
anime i'm very curious to see the
results you know meanwhile if you
enjoyed this countdown you might want to
consider supporting vinitube through its
two channels membership and patreon i'd
be very glad if i can get your support
as we march towards the channel's next
milestone because i know that together
between us we can definitely do it don't
forget to check out our sponsors of this
video
expressvpn all you have to do is click
the link in the description box or go to
expressvpn.com
vinnie tube for a three month free trial
that's all for today thank you for
watching and hope you have a good day
[Music]